hi guys i'm abby schart welcome to
abby's kitchen today we're going to be
covering a question that i get
asked about a lot and that is how to fix
metabolic damage or a slow metabolism
from extreme dieting
this is something that is incredibly
common since for a lot of people
weight loss diets are just not
sustainable in the long term
and often results in weight regain
otherwise known as
weight cycling but why is weight
regained after it's lost
and why do some people regain even more
weight
than what they lost in the first place
the reason for this is what we call
metabolic adaptation so today on the
channel
i'll be talking all things metabolic
adaptation or metabolic damage how the
body responds to weight loss
and what you can do to restore your
metabolism before we begin a reminder
that the information this video is for
entertainment and educational purposes
only
and you should always seek out the help
of a registered dietitian or medical
professional
for your unique case okay so first
things first
what is metabolic damage anyway
while metabolic damage and starvation
mode are really commonly used as terms
online
i actually prefer to use the term
metabolic adaptation
to refer to the body's response to
long-term caloric restriction
or starvation the term metabolic damage
tends to make this seem like a really
negative unfortunate side effect of
calorie restriction or extreme dieting
when in fact metabolic adaptation is a
normal
and natural survival mechanism when our
body does not have enough energy aka
calories available to use
it slows down our metabolism to burn
fewer calories throughout the day
this is literally a desperate attempt to
preserve
energy for the body to use for normal
everyday functions
like breathing digestion walking
standing etc
there are several metabolic mechanisms
that influence our body weight
a lot of people might believe that it's
as simple as energy in
minus energy out but it's actually a lot
more nuanced than that
based on what we know about metabolic
adaptation and weight cycling
the ability of a person to lose a
significant amount of weight for good
and to keep it off is really up for
debate
so let's look at things from a metabolic
calculation perspective and consider
what would actually be required to
change your body weight
when we consider the idea that energy in
equals energy out
the energy in aspect of this equation
realistically looks more like the
actual number of calories consumed minus
the calories that are
not actually absorbed from the food when
we consider the actual number of
calories consumed
this information may not be as accurate
as you may think
depending on where you look for instance
calorie information is readily available
from
food packaging or calorie trackers
however according to the fda
the nutrition information on a food
label can be off by up to 20 percent
and still be considered compliant so the
calories that you see on a nutrition
label
or the numbers you're logging into your
myfitnesspal may be
very different than when you're actually
consuming
now when we think about calorie
absorption the number of calories in
food
may not equal the number of calories you
actually absorb
rates of absorption can and do vary
depending on things like
how food is processed and cooked the
fiber content of the food
our microbiome makeup etc on the other
hand
energy out is a combination of resting
metabolic rate
the thermic effect of food physical
activity and non-exercise
activity thermogenesis resting metabolic
rate or rmr
is the number of calories that you burn
each day simply at rest
rmr supports body functions like
breathing blood circulation
organ function and brain function and is
largely dependent on genetics
age sex weight and possibly gut
microflora as well
rmr represents about 60 percent of our
energy output aka
our metabolism now the thermic effect of
food or
tee is the amount of energy or calories
required to eat
digest and absorb food the amount of
energy expenditure
varies per macronutrient for example
carbohydrates and fat require five to
fifteen percent of your energy output to
digest
while protein requires twenty to thirty
five percent then there's physical
activity which is the energy expenditure
during purposeful activity like
going to the gym or going for a walk or
riding your bike etc
obviously this piece is highly variable
depending on
an individual's unique activity level
and then there's non-exercise activity
thermogenesis
or neat and that is all the little
unconscious things that you may do
that use up energy like fidgeting or
sitting up straight which i'm bad at
playing a musical instrument twirling
your hair anxiously etc
this makes up about 10 to 15 of your
total energy output
so to summarize changes in body weight
look less like this
and more like this so when our body
weight changes
how does metabolic adaptation happen
well metabolic adaptation research is
largely based on theories
like the setpoint theory and the dual
intervention point theory
the setpoint theory suggests that our
bodies have a comfortable weight that is
genetically predetermined
that it will fight to defend when we
decrease our intake and lower our body
weight through dieting for example
we have compensatory mechanisms in place
that reduce the energy output
and increase the energy input in an
effort to maintain homeostasis
our weight in this regard is a lot like
a thermostat
if the house gets too hot it's triggered
to cool it back down
if the house gets cold it's triggered to
heat it back up the dual intervention
point theory considers that we
genetically have a set point
but that it's not a static number but
rather it's more
of a range outside of the upper and
lower intervention points or
setpoint range physiological control
mechanisms get
switched on to bring us back into that
range
however when our weight falls within the
setpoint range
these control mechanisms are a lot
weaker to give you an example
if your set point range is 110 to 135
pounds
because the physiological control
mechanisms for weight
are weaker within this range this range
can be more
easily influenced and may fluctuate up
or down
depending on things like diet and
exercise
however these efforts are more likely to
be thwarted
if you try to get outside the range so
for example
if you want to get down to 100 pounds or
up to 160 pounds
it's important to note that there is no
one range
size and individuals will vary in how
tight
their set point range is since
everyone's upper and lower intervention
boundaries aka setpoint range
are different and variable in their
width it helps explain
why some people's weights maybe seem
like they're more tightly regulated than
others
i mean we all know somebody who can eat
anything and
they just stay the same weight while
others have an extra beer on the weekend
and they gain weight the former likely
has a very
narrow setpoint range so their body
works
harder to keep them within that range
while the latter
may have a wider range meaning their
weight is more likely to fluctuate to a
greater degree
based on these theories when we restrict
calories
and we lose weight below the lower
intervention threshold
aka the setpoint range a few major
energy
out mechanisms kick in to bring the body
back to homeostasis
one we have less energy available to
push ourselves hard in the gym
aka physical activity declines two we
may unconsciously fidget or move less so
our
neat declines three we may absorb more
calories from food to compensate
for the lack of caloric intake tee
decreases
and four we weigh less so our body needs
fewer calories
to sustain that lower weight aka our rmr
decreases
to summarize all aspects of the energy
out equation
decline in effort to balance out the
restricted energy in
and bring the body back within its
normal weight range
unfortunately it would appear that this
is not a precise
science as metabolism aka energy out or
energy expenditure
may decline more than when you'd expect
for the change in body weight
likely as a survival mechanism to
safeguard against body and fat mass laws
we saw the survival mechanism play out
in the popular weight loss reality tv
show
the biggest losers results from a
six-year follow-up study on 14
contestants from the show showed that
not only did contestants
regain the weight that they lost in a
lot of cases but some contestants
gain even more weight than what they
weighed prior to participating on the
show
one of the most significant findings of
this study was the dramatic decline in
resting metabolic rate
after this weight loss meaning they
burned fewer calories
about 500 fewer in energy expenditure
than they did before they competed on
the show
these results suggest that metabolic
adaptations
or a slow metabolism is actually a
defense mechanism
that acts in proportion to weight loss
so for example
if you needed a 2000 calorie diet at 150
pounds
and the mathematical equation would
suggest that you might need 1500
calories
at 130 pounds after you lose 20 pounds
the sad reality may suggest that you
would
actually need only a thousand calories
to maintain your new 130 pound weight
ugh no wonder people who lose weight
gain it back of course i want to just
quickly note that those were just
fictitious
numbers that i made up to make a point
so don't go thinking
that those are the amount of calories
that you need to maintain a certain
weight anyway in addition to changes in
metabolic rate
our hormones will likewise adjust to
compensate for changes in body weight
which can influence the energy in
equation
for instance when we lose weight a few
major things
happen first setpoint theory puts leptin
our satiety hormone front and center as
the main compensatory
player for decreased caloric intake
leptin stored in fat cells is our
satiety hormone
and signals to us when we feel full when
we lose weight
these fat cells shrink and leptin levels
drop meaning
our normal healthy fullness signals
become silenced
as a result we feel the need to eat more
to feel full as our body
fights to regain its preferred weight
now ghrelin
our hunger hormone is inversely related
to caloric
intake this means when we eat fewer
calories than what our body needs
ghrelin revs up and increases our
appetite
studies show that people who try to lose
weight and keep it off
end up producing more ghrelin than they
did before losing weight
then cortisol also known as the stress
hormone
is often released under severe caloric
restriction
or excessive exercise increased cortisol
can slow metabolism
and impair the ability to sustainably
lose weight
some studies have even shown that women
who consume
low calorie diets have higher cortisol
levels
and report more feelings of stress
compared to women who do not restrict
their diet
in addition when we experience an
increase in cortisol
we also experience an increase in our
insulin resistance
this would mean that cells become less
sensitive to insulin
resulting in higher blood sugar levels
which we know is a risk factor for type
2 diabetes
all of these compensatory mechanisms
become common responses to severe
weight loss caloric restriction and
yo-yo dieting
as the body fights to maintain its
natural set point weight
or weight range the most common signs
and symptoms of metabolic adaptation
include things like fatigue heartburn
digestive stress
increased hunger sleep disturbances
weight gain
anxiety loss of muscle period
irregularity
and low immunity so how can
a damaged metabolism be restored back to
normal homeostasis
after a period of restriction well two
of the most common ways to restore
metabolism
are through reverse dieting and the
all-in approach
first let's talk about reverse dieting
so reverse dieting is
exactly as it sounds and is often called
the
diet after the diet it's a way of eating
that is
usually performed after a diet or a
period of restriction
this entails progressively increasing
calories
over a certain period of time to boost
up resting metabolic rate back to its
original rate the truth is that there
isn't a lot of peer-reviewed research
on reverse dieting i mean this is a
method that is largely being used in the
fitness competition and sports nutrition
area
and success is largely anecdotal
in lieu of adequate scientific research
i spoke to two
sports dietitians to get their thoughts
chelsea cross of
mc dietetics and ben sit of evolved
sport and nutrition
now under the care of a sports dietitian
like these two
a client attempting reverse dieting
would increase their calories by about
50 to 100 calories per week they would
do this until
a caloric goal weight goal or a
perceived
set point was reached there can be a lot
of experimentation involved in this so
it is best to do this
with the guidance of a dietitian but
because the progression
is so slow and calculated there is a
lower risk of
overshooting the desired weight as with
any diet that involves adding calories
after a period of restriction
benson did explain to me that it is very
important to monitor for the signs
and symptoms of refeeding syndrome now
re-feeding syndrome occurs when somebody
with a low body weight
consuming a very low calorie diet over a
sustained
period of time dramatically increases
their calories
this can cause a potentially fatal shift
in fluid and electrolyte balance
due to a spike in insulin in response to
greater caloric intake
this is often a major concern in eating
disorder recovery
but it can also actually occur after
prolonged dieting
or restrictive eating both of these
dietitians agreed that a caloric
increase
of 50 to 100 calories per week is
generally safe to prevent refeeding
syndrome
and not likely to result in extreme fat
or weight gain
however some people can tolerate a
greater amount of calories
outside of this range while others need
to be more conservative
and this is why again it is very
important to work with a professional
on your reverse dieting journey now
let's talk about the
all-in approach now the all-in approach
is a process created by dr nicola
rinaldi
which was informed by previous treatment
methods used in eating disorder recovery
it was originally developed to restore
hormonal function quickly
in order to reverse symptoms of
hypothalamic amenorrhea
such as menstrual regularity extreme
hunger
lack of libido infertility and
temperature sensitivity
the all-in approach is now often used to
restore metabolic function
albeit faster than reverse dieting one
study looked at the resting metabolism
of women who had hypothalamic amenorrhea
and then again when they recovered from
their aha and in addition to their
hormones returning to normal
the difference in metabolism was an
impressive 300 calories a day
now you might recall my videos on
stephanie bettermore's all-in journey
stephanie had a regular cycle so she
wasn't necessarily trying to use
all in for menstrual regularity as it
was originally intended she was using
all in to help her
reset some of the side effects of her
dieting past like extreme hunger
and help her settle into her set point
weight so
how do you go all in now in dr rinaldi's
book no period now what
she suggests that recovery involves
three main pillars
which she encourages people to stick to
for a minimum of six months
to see a complete recovery these
requirements include
a following her meal plan daily which
aims for a minimum of 2500 calories a
day
without a maximum and allowing yourself
to eat to full satiety
two cutting out all high intensity
exercise
and three reducing stress and making
time to relax
it's not uncommon for people who have
come off of a period of intense
restriction
to experience what we call extreme
hunger
and therefore need a lot of calories to
recover
this is your body's way of begging not
only for enough calories to return to
baseline
but also to help replenish itself after
months
or years of under fueling it since the
body is operating at a lower metabolic
rate while consuming a sub-optimal
amount of calories
once you jump up to the 2500 calorie
minimum
it's expected that you will gain weight
and fat
this is normal in fact rinaldi suggests
that weight gain tends to bring people
into a bmi of around 22 or more which
is what she calls the fertile zone
everyone's fertile weight is different
and it may in fact be a lot higher than
the weight that you aesthetically
think that you should be the weight gain
may therefore be
just a little bit or it could be a lot
you may also gain what is often termed
overshoot weight
this is a term that rinaldi herself
really dislikes
and for good reason considering the
moral weight stigma inherently attached
to it
but essentially some people who follow
the all-in approach
find that they may initially gain extra
weight
but that as their metabolism adjusts
this weight kind of
resettles back down slightly and
plateaus
while this does not happen to everyone
and a lot of people
may simply plateau at a higher weight
when they reach their true set point
if it does occur it may be for a few
different reasons one is that the
initial weight gain may cause changes in
fluid
and electrolyte storage which can cause
water retention
and bloating two is that some people
particularly those who come from a
distorted eating history may have very
high caloric needs when they begin all
in as they not only need calories for
baseline needs
but also for repairing and refueling
damaged metabolism systems
over time once the repairing is complete
these caloric needs may drop
and regulate to just cover those
baseline needs
and three at the beginning of the all-in
journey
one's metabolism will likely be pretty
slow
which can result in some quick sometimes
significant
jumps on the scale but once metabolism
catches up and adjusts to the new
incoming caloric load it's possible that
we would see
the weight come down and stabilize like
i said rinaldi
strongly dislikes even discussing
overshoot weight
since it gives the impression that it's
only okay to gain weight because
you'll lose a lot of it once things
stabilize when in fact
gaining weight even if it's a lot of
weight and not losing a single pound
may be very necessary for maintaining
health
so what are the benefits and
disadvantages of reverse dieting versus
all in
well evidence on reverse dieting and its
alleged benefits is admittedly
lacking but experts who do use this
strategy with their clients
find that the slow stepwise method to
increasing caloric intake
allows for gradual metabolic adaptation
and reduces the risk of gaining excess
fat and weight
while preserving lean muscle mass this
is largely based on anecdotal evidence
and
not from actual research studies the
downside is that reverse dieting
like any dieting may not be appropriate
for those struggling with disordered
eating which is
actually not uncommon for people coming
from
an extreme diet or pattern of
restriction carefully counting calories
with a goal
of metabolic restoration with minimal
weight gain
can further perpetuate distorted eating
and will not help an individual
ease back into a more flexible healthy
relationship with food and their body
there is also a concern that because the
goal of reverse dieting
is to slowly bump up caloric intake
without risking weight or fat gain an
individual may never
actually ever reach their body's true
set point weight
instead they may continue to be fueling
their body at a sub-optimal level
for their unique needs but stopping
when their goal weight or desired weight
is threatened by a further caloric
increase
the other concern is that reverse
dieting does not achieve metabolic
restoration very quickly
so for those who are suffering with the
physiological health implications of
metabolic damage like hypothalamic and
manoria
infertility thyroid dysfunction or other
hormonal irregularities
they may not achieve the timely recovery
that they really truly need in contrast
the all-in approach
is arguably the most efficient way to
restore hormonal regulation
and by default of course metabolism
following a period of restriction
this will mean improvements in
everything from sleep
menstrual cycle thyroid hunger and
fullness cues etc
it's also a more intuitive approach that
can help you reach your body's natural
set point
while relearning often for the first
time in a really long time
how to listen to your body's true hunger
and fullness cues
in my professional opinion i consider
the all-in approach to be
true recovery from restriction while
reverse dieting
can offer some significant health
benefits
it may not allow for full healing to
occur
both psychologically and in some cases
physically
in other words all in is exactly what it
sounds like when it comes to
refueling your body while reverse
dieting may not be going
all the way but some of the way at a
much slower pace
it could get you all the way but it also
could not
so how do you know if you should go all
in or reverse diet to restore metabolism
well it really depends on the goals and
the health concerns of the individual
a faster reverse diet or an all-in
approach may be beneficial for somebody
having complications with their health
due to a low caloric intake in contrast
a slow meticulous reverse diet may be
beneficial for those who
want to increase their caloric intake
while minimizing fat gain
and maintaining muscle mass as best as
they can i would argue that a reverse
diet may not be suitable for anybody
with a past or present history of
disordered eating who
really should be focusing on regaining
body trust
not on another weight driven diet even
if it is one that involves
adding calories to the diet some people
may choose an
all-in approach if they are looking to
balance and restore their hormones
metabolism and their general health at a
much faster rate
while also of course working on the
relationship with food and their body
whichever one you choose again it is so
important
that you work with a registered
dietitian to ensure that this is done
safely
and properly especially if you're coming
out from a very
restrictive low-calorie diet other than
increasing caloric intake through all-in
or reverse dieting
there are a few additional ways to
attempt to improve metabolism
number one is reducing intense exercise
we know that exercise is so important
but it can become problematic when it's
excessive not supported by adequate
caloric intake
or affecting you mentally intense
exercise will not only burn the calories
that you're carefully trying to add
during metabolic restoration but it can
also increase
stress hormones like cortisol cortisol
like we talked about
high cortisol has been shown to increase
insulin and blood glucose levels
which in turn has been linked to
increased risk of obesity
and slowed metabolism so pull back on
any long or intense cardio sessions
and stick to gentle strength training
yoga stretching
and easy walks instead number two is
getting more sleep
sleep allows our body to repair itself
physically and mentally
research suggests that when sleep is
restricted cortisol levels rise which
does tend to play a role in metabolism
and weight gain over time
skimping on sleep also seems to further
reduce
leptin and increase ghrelin to hormones
that are already impacted by metabolic
damage
three is reducing stress now stress can
of course be in the form of
intense exercise or lack of sleep but it
can also take
shape from other life experiences and
factors as well
all of which can increase cortisol
levels so look for ways to reduce the
stress in your life by engaging in
relaxing activities
like meditation journaling talk therapy
yoga or other acts of self-care so what
is the bottom line on reversing
metabolic damage
the truth is if you want to improve your
metabolism and
fix metabolic damage after a period of
severe caloric restriction
there are two popular methods to do so
one is the more calculated but
arguably less effective method at
achieving full metabolic restoration
reverse dieting
while the other is more aggressive but
faster and a more thorough approach
the all-in approach gaining weight and
body fat
may be part of the process regardless of
which method you choose
and it may in fact be necessary for
overall health
whichever method you choose to reverse
metabolic adaptation
it's very important that you're working
with a registered dietitian and
if you're coming from an eating disorder
history a full
medical team and that is of course to
ensure that you're not
at risk of refeeding syndrome well folks
that is all for today's video
if you liked it be sure to give it that
thumbs up leave me a comment below if
you have any big
questions that you want me to tackle
subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
you